I want to talk about jobs and President
Obama there's a bigger question about
jobs right do presidents create jobs
through their policies or don't they if
you believe that presidents do create
jobs or at least that their policies
influence job creation then no matter
what letter you have after your name on
your party registration you have to
praise President Obama because he has
presided over the longest streak of
total job growth in history 78 months
and counting seven eight the recent
August jobs report shows that businesses
have added 15 point 1 million job since
early 2010 I have a graphic I'll show
you which sort of outlines uh the the
way this went and you will see of course
uh President Obama taking office in the
first month of two thousand nine uh and
then a lot of jobs added there the
unemployment rate also down to four
point nine percent if Mitt Romney had
been elected president and had these
numbers Republicans would be demanding
that Romney's face be chiseled into
Mount Rushmore right now and I'll go
even further do you remember when Mitt
Romney was making his predictions for
what would happen with jobs if he were
president Mitt Romney said it's on video
look it up if I am president at the end
of my first term unemployment will be
down to six percent in January of 2017
and that will be because I will have
repealed the Affordable Care Act known
as Obamacare president Obama has gotten
us to four point nine percent
unemployment in less time than Mitt
Romney said he would need without
repealing the Affordable Care Act now if
you don't think presidents create jobs
uh if if uh that's your view I would I
would debate that with you I mean
economic policy trade agreements tax
policy labor policy those are all
elements that influence job creation and
the president is definitely involved in
all of
those areas that being said I am NOT
here to tell you that everything is just
Rosie when it comes to wages and jobs
and unemployment uh we have a situation
as far as wages go that is very very
problematic we have a situation that is
coming towards us like a comet or
asteroid or whatever whatever you want
to call it meteor I'm not actually sure
I'd Neil deGrasse Tyson told me what the
difference is between these and I'm just
forgetting like one of these big hunks
of rock that is a I know one of them is
ice I'm really digging a hole here but
let's move on and go with a different
analogy this is like a huge ship heading
towards an iceberg that is too heavy to
be steered away we are getting towards
technological unemployment growing that
goes well beyond President Obama or
Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton or
whoever so I'm not here to tell you
there's no concerns in the economy what
I am here to tell you is that using the
standards that have been in place for
decades for measuring job creation and
unemployment there is no empirical way
to deny that President Obama has
overseen one of the greatest periods of
job creation in the last hundred and
fifty or more years let me take a break
after the break we've got to just dispel
one of these conspiracy theories that
has been making the rounds and I tried
to stay away but the audience has spoken
they want me to address it so I will
after the break